hey rich and adam uh my name is kevin
from the st louis area and i have a
question about
productivity of sorts so i'm sitting
here today
watching the events unfold at the
capitol building trying to comprehend
what's going on
and how we've gotten to this point i'm
also using this time amongst other times
in 2020 to reflect on my privileges
actions and my roles for a better
tomorrow i also have full-time studies
as a medical student that today in
particular i find very difficult to
focus on
in the midst of a global pandemic as
well i find it difficult to be
productive
i feel the expectations of my position
as a student and during normal time
school
school is hard enough as it is my mind
tells me that what i'm doing has less
importance when our country is hurting
so much
my question for you and rich is your
advice on how to focus on school and
maybe for others their job
and to maintain some semblance of what
you're supposed to be doing that that's
all that's going on i'm finding it hard
at times to be getting a groove with all
of this
thanks for all your insights and
discussion to both of you
they mean a lot to me have a good one
thanks bye all right thanks kevin for
that question
obviously this question was lodged some
weeks ago
yeah in the midst of the insurrection
and i think
you know the sentiment that he's
conveying is pretty human and pretty
normal i
i suspect you know a lot of people will
will relate to that and
it's indicative of you know a very
strange and extraordinary
time that we're all living through where
we're all trying to do our best
i was glued to that we're holding we're
holding ourselves to
a standard of behavior of how we would
operate in a normal
situation and these are not normal
situations so the first thing i would
say is like give yourself
a break a little bit right now be a
little
gracious with yourself and that's not to
say
let yourself off the hook but i think
it's okay
to take a breather and not beat yourself
up for
feeling unproductive in in this moment
in terms of of how to move forward i
mean my my advice is pretty
straightforward and
and simple and basic i mean the first
thing is
try to control the controllables there's
so much about this that we have no
control over we have no agency over it
the only things we do have control over
is our behaviors and our thoughts and
our interactions
you're in medical school so what's you
know the thing in front of you that you
need to get done
and break those tasks down into
bite-sized chunks and
try to execute on them you know in the
best way possible just do the least
amount that you need to do
to engender a little bit of of momentum
and and and just look for the next right
thing you know i think it's incumbent
upon you
as a medical student and somebody's
clearly very busy it's okay to take a
break from the news like the news will
be the news and you don't have to be
you know hamstrung in your life because
of the news cycle
like you can take that in chunks as well
at certain points of the day if you feel
you need to
but the news will continue and exist
whether you're consuming it or not
um i also sense a little bit of
of guilt or maybe even shame like i feel
this person feels like
they want to contribute and be of
service
in a way that they're not feeling
connected to in
the moment and i think it's important to
just figure out how to be a giver in
your own way that doesn't mean
that you have to raise your hand and be
some kind of prominent voice
in a political movement but in your own
universe you you know can be of service
to
i don't know if you're dealing with
patients yet but your fellow students
and your professors like how can you
uh exercise small gestures in a giving
type of way that make you feel more
connected to the people around you
and engender uh you know a tighter a
tighter community
on the privileged piece look you know
it's fine to acknowledge your privilege
but i don't think that you should feel
guilty about the position that you're in
i'm sure you worked very hard to be
where you're at
and you know if there's anything
you don't have to atone for it but like
i think it's
you should make the most of it uh and
just to be the best doctor that you can
be
in service to other people so
to the extent that you may not be able
to make a difference you know
geopolitically you can find meaning and
fulfillment in your work
and that is your unique lever
for making a difference and i think as a
doctor you can make a tremendous amount
of difference
in so many people's lives so give
yourself a break it's a pandemic things
are weird they're hard
it's all okay just do what's in front of
you
beautiful i agree i think sometimes like
these bigger story lines that are
floating over us
they take on this incredible importance
because
they they call in to question kind of
these stories
that we've been telling ourselves about
who we are and where we live and what
the people around us
are up to and they're paralyzed and
they're paralyzing but in reality
real life happens super local it's on
the ground right around you
and all that unless we lived in dc it
didn't affect us really like
so um it affected us emotionally but it
wasn't
like it didn't change our abilities to
move around in our
in our localities right and so um
i think you're right like finding
keeping it super local keeping it simple
sometimes
is the answer but you know that's coming
from a guy who literally couldn't do
anything for like five days so
i'm with you yeah with you st louis
[Music]
you